[Musique]
dans un an auront lieu les 11e jeux des
îles de l'océan indien madagascar
à quelques mois de cette grande
compétition le club réunion a voulu
faire un point d'étape en présence des
partenaires les sportifs à la réunion
attendent les jeux des îles c'est pour
eux aussi à une forme d'aboutissement
mais un passage pour aller vers le plus
haut niveau pour aller en métropole ou
sur l'album nationale donc voilà il
vient lui confrontation internationale
déjà à notre niveau de l'océan indien et
appelé ça le voeu que les ordis cher et
des années sur le chemin de la réussite
le département tenait à être présent à
cette conférence de presse pour exprimer
son soutien total à cet événement
nous accompagnons effectivement
l'organisation des ligues et les comités
à travers une subvention donc sans son
10000 euros cette année et sans soins
dix mille euros l'année prochaine une
enveloppe aussi été très bio cross pour
l'organisation de ces jeux de 450000
euros et bien sûr on tenait aussi à
mettre en avant et c'est ce qui a été
fait aujourd'hui le plan 5000 licence
donc il permet aux familles aujourd'hui
à travers une à du département de
pouvoir participer à la licence sportive
qui est extrêmement important le sport
est vecteur d'insertion vecteur aussi
l'intégration sociale et surtout sa
transe riz des valeurs qui sont
complètement en phase avec celle que le
département différent les jeux des îles
de l'océan indien sont une manifestation
sportive qui se déroule tous les quatre
ans 25 disciplines permettront 550
athlètes de se confronter à deux ans des
jeux olympiques de paris
[Musique]